hey everyone before we get into the
video i just want to let you know we've
got some brand new
friendly neighborhood spoiler man merch
available right now
we've just launched this great design
that you can get on t-shirts coffee cups
socks and phone cases i know some of you
have been asking for some
some better merch in the store beyond
just the logo and this one has some cool
easter eggs on it
that really show the devils in the
detail hey
i just want to give a huge thank you to
everyone who's got one so far
it really helps the channel out and
means that you can support us and get
something back from it
if you want to buy one then click just
below the video you should see the merch
section
and thank you for everyone who who helps
make my dreams come true
and means i can keep doing breakdowns
like this hope you enjoy the rest of the
day
take care thank you
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
your friendly neighborhood spoiler man
and with venom let there be carnage
getting its first trailer this week
i thought we dive into some of the plot
leaks that we have on the marvel movie
andy circus did a big trailer breakdown
with ign that
i'm definitely definitely not angry
about and throughout this video we're
going to be discussing what the director
said
and how it lines up with certain things
that we've heard on the film
bulls spoilers ahead so if you don't
want anything ruined then i recommend
that you swing out of here
otherwise there's gonna be some carnage
a smash the thumbs up button if you
enjoy it
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
worth sticking around for
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our venom let
there be carnage plot leaks
okay so the film takes place not too
long after the post-credits scene from
the first movie
circus has discussed how eddie brock is
the only person that cletus cassidy is
willing to talk to
and there's a lot of mystery surrounding
the character he's scheduled to be
executed on death row
but the killer has a number of hidden
victims that the world is still unaware
of
brock is desperate to unearth who these
people are before cassidy is killed
and thus he starts to physically as more
and more to get to the bottom of it
circus stated that the death chamber for
cletus was a complete replica of the one
from san quentin
and i love that they're paying this much
attention to detail according to leaks
we are also going to be exploring
a lot of things from cassidy's past this
includes his childhood
which is supposed to be heavily in line
with the comics
in the source material when he was
growing up cassidy used to witness his
father
brutally abuse his mother in front of
him his dad would berate him and call
him weak
and thus he got the impression that in
order to be strong
he had to be abusive too thus he began
to torture and kill animals
and slowly his mind was warped by the
violence around him
cassidy actually killed his grandmother
by pushing her down a flight of steps
and he attempted to murder his mother
too one day when she was taking a bath
he tried to toss a hairdryer into it and
she finally snapped and attempted to
murder her son
the details of what happened next are
unclear but it was thought that cletus's
dad killed her
though many suspected that it was the
boy child services moved him to saint
esther's orphanage
which further sent him down a darker
path cletus was bullied
and this heightened his belief that he
had to be abusive in order to be strong
cassidy ended up pushing a girl in front
of a bus and he set fire to the
orphanage
burning it to the ground now there is a
shot in the trailer where we see a
building on fire
this may potentially be the orphanage
itself though
circus didn't clear this moment up in
his trailer breakdown
which definitely go check out mine
instead because it's it's much better
now
when discussing shriek he did bring up
the fact that she had a childhood
sweetheart
but wouldn't say who it was he was
acting
very precious over that a and if you're
familiar with the comics
then you'll know that shriek was
cletus's girlfriend and that the pair
had a relationship through several of
the books also yeah before you start
getting angry i was just joking about my
trailer breakdown being better yeah
i don't think i'm better than the
director you idiot anyway i think you'd
have to be the only clown at the circus
a to not figure out that the pair likely
met at the orphanage and that this is
where they fell in love
oh serial killers so cute
now how she gained her abilities and at
what point they got separated
we don't know but i think that there
will be a big part in the movie that
highlights cletus's childhood
and how he met her according to the
leaks this all gets told to us through
brock's reporting
and he now works for the daily bugle
though we don't know if he's in the
movie for definite
jk simmons has said that he's due to
appear in several spider-man properties
from sony
so you can expect to see him show up
here and immobius
he of course appeared at the end of far
from home as well so it makes sense for
him to cameo in no way home
now the bugle logo on both the paper and
brock's laptop
is exactly the same as how it was in the
rainy movies
so expect some nods here and there
circus said that there are hints to the
greatest spider-verse in this film
but the characters in this movie don't
actually know that he exists so i don't
think that we will be diving directly
into the mcu just yet
but with the multiverse opening up
anything is possible
except for you getting a girlfriend you
loser anyway brock announced that cletus
had 12 extra victims
and this massively bumps up his body
count he ends up traveling to the
orphanage which is where he discovers
even more bad things about cletus's past
and apparently this is how he unearths
his origins
now the reports are also being followed
by a policeman named mulligan
played by stephen graham now why this is
interesting is because mulligan in the
comics
goes on to become toxin aka the son of
carnage
patrick mulligan himself was a policeman
too so it does seem like he will indeed
go on to become the character
i can't find any references to him in
the leaks so whether this happens in the
film or not
i really don't know what's more likely
though is that we will get a tease
towards him becoming the villain
at the end of the movie much in the same
way that carnage was set up
at the end of the last film at one point
we can see mulligan slam the paper shut
and get a brief glimpse of another
headline which seems to read
avengers league nightmare now for
something that isn't apparently
connected to the mcu
this is still a cool little easter egg
and it could be a nod to how one that
ended up leaving the hex
though that is just as theorizing now we
also know that there's a prison break in
the film
and typically in the comics this is
where cletus was infected with the
symbiote
i think with venom operating as an
anti-hero that he will venture to the
prison
during the riots and this is how cletus
will end up coming into contact with
carnage
the leaks that dropped for the film last
year did state that there was a prison
riot scene in which he became infected
and as they popped up on the internet
way before the trailer
i think they hold some weight circus has
confirmed that the execution scene will
actually be the birth of carnage and
perhaps his host almost being killed
is what springs him into action now from
the trailers we know that ravencroft is
going to be making a big appearance too
this is pretty much a home for
supervillains that has housed many of
them over the years
sri can be seen there in the trailers
and even the guards that go and visit
her
have to wear giant headphones to protect
their ears
likely showing that she's had her powers
for quite a long time
she can be seen in a cell shrieking and
this sends
papers flying everywhere now my dad
actually owned a paper shop
and one day it blew away hey having that
anyway carnage goes to rescue her
and the two end up teaming up carnage
causes well carnage and shriek dwell
and from here they travel to a church
which is where venom goes to take both
of them down
sonics are often used to defeat
symbiotes but weirdly carnage is less
vulnerable to them
than venom is i don't know whether
they're going to include that in the
movie or not but it's gonna make for a
really interesting fight
that i think will hopefully create toxin
during it
now with all leaks there are the less
believable ones that inevitably make
their way to reddit
4chan my mate dude bro trust me and my
uncle's iphone 20
which he bought directly from bill gates
swear down from
not lying anyway my uncle did say that
the film ends with venom
reaching out to spider-man for help but
i'm not 100 on this
it's something i'll say take with a
grain of salt but the raw leaks out
there that states spider-man do show up
for the final battle to help brock take
down carnage
according to them venom wants to kill
cassidy at the end of the movie
but spider-man stops him and this is
what starts their rivalry
tom hardy did post a photo of venom
eating spider-man to his instagram page
and he quickly deleted it my uncle did
screenshot it though but whether that's
true or not
we really don't know carnage also smacks
down a spider in the trailer but i think
that's just a cool easter egg to
accompany the line about heroes
now personally and and don't tell my
uncle this year please don't tell him
i don't think that spider-man is gonna
be in the movie and i think the final
battle will be between carnage shriek
and of course venom
is that a church and carnage is in a
christ-like pose so there is a lot of
religious imagery going on with it
the phrase let there be is also steeped
in religion too
so this seems like the best setting for
it all to go down
now those are all the leaks i could find
and what annie circus has said about the
movie
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
drawing the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kung collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the leaks
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we pointed out all the cool little
easter eggs in it
and also give out theories on what would
be happening in the film so definitely
give it a watch right after this
and don't go and click ign yet i don't
care if they've got andy circus
i've got kevin's spoilers anyway i'll
see you over there
now go on click it goodbye